[Music]  [Music]  hmm  i can't play with you i'm too busy  tinkle stop i said no  no go away  a little privacy tingles i swear  bad tinkles no no  no no  ah  don't you have anyone else to play with  wait a second that's  it oh tinkles  i have a little surprise for you  [Music]  oh don't worry what we need  is a monster dog like  [Music]  lollipop  [Music]  say hello oh booty steins  [Music]  come on it's not that weird  okay he's weird what about swampy  next diablo  next spike  pebbles  tiny slithers sharky  mr tentacles whatever this thing is  next what the last one  oh boy this had better work oh  tinkles great news  i found you the perfect monster pet to  play with  say hello to your new best friend  sand  [Music]  dog  stop sit here  [Music]  great now who are you going to play with  hmm  oh  oh  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  you